[Musique]
jorane merci de nous accueillir dans
votre lieu de création c'est ici que
vous avez réalisé en partie et menaient
17 oui votre mii grands projets six ans
de travail
j'ai vu les images du temps un spectacle
assez grandiose mais effets visuels vous
costumer que voulez vous faire je
voulais pousser à l'extrême si on veut
les émotions qu'on pouvait ressentir
musique je voulais qu'on puisse voir la
musique oui musicalement ce spectacle là
sans aucun effet on peut le jouer mais
j'avais envie d'offrir aussi une
musicienne nous ya la possibilité d'être
autrement sur scène tout le monde a
accepté de sortir de sa zone de confort
pour moi c'est important donc pour ce
spectacle là le projet en fait de réunir
un plusieurs formes d'art de la
technologie d'avant-garde et 3 le sens
du rituel de la connaît
c'est sage utilise beaucoup la voient
comme un instrument ça c'est intéressant
ce que vous dites parce que la première
fois que je les rencontre et vous avez
un loft à montréal vont vivre et hama
pour l'amuser ont pas trop d'argent mais
très jeune vous savez exactement où vous
en à lille c'est très drôle parce que je
viens à côté mais
se heurte là je n'avais qu'une plante
et mon violoncelle et juste avant quand
j'habitais encore à québec c'était la
même chose j'avais une chaise mon
violoncelle un petit frigo j'ai toujours
adoré avoir un endroit totalement vide
seulement pour pouvoir pratiquer mon
violoncelle c'est comme ça que j'ai vécu
oui mes premières années alors que
j'étais encore à l'étude dénonce l est
c'est drôle parce que pendant la coved
et j'ai dû m'isoler j'étais ici sur un
matelas et j'étais tellement heureuse de
pouvoir dormir à côté des guitares vous
piano comme dans le temps il ya eu un
moment au moins j'espère m'y suis très
content tout d'abord ce moment là c'est
très drôle
vous partagez votre vie depuis près de
20 ans avec éloi painchaud d'okoumé
enseignements mais maintenant avec sale
bah oui comment l'un et l'autre vous
vous nourrissez musicalement on est
loin et moi on peut toujours parler
musique que nous arrive de jouer du quai
john lui et moi ensemble le soir on va
de l'aisne louis
en fait on est toujours les premières le
premier témoin de ce que l'on a composé
et c'est toujours le moment super
important quand on dit ok là c'est
prévient bien écouter j'aimerais ça se
fera entendre quelque chose puis on a
appris avec les années aussi
à écouter la bonne façon les premières
idées parce que c'est tellement de
moments fragiles
[Applaudissements]
vous n'êtes pas parle depuis plus pour
l'organisme le phare enfants et familles
qui vient en aide aux enfants gravement
malades et à leurs familles et ça vous
touche parce que votre premier garçon
manolo et la 15 ans il est atteint d'une
maladie dégénérative et j'ai
l'impression que cette épreuve attentes
et votre musique c'est sûr que notre
premier enfant parce qu'on a trois
garçons
le premier on ne le vit vraiment un pouf
dans la face dans le coeur parce qu'on
on a été dans les premières semaines
mise à l'épreuve vraiment avec
avec une situation qui pouvait vraiment
mais ça c'est son jeu sa vie se jouer à
tout bout de champ alors on habitait
dans les hôpitaux où vraiment dans les
premières années de notre vie avec mon
boulot j'ai dû lui annuler des tournées
et je n'avais pas le choix et c'était
pas et pas de question pour moi ce n'est
voilà j'avais toujours dit que
j'adapterai ma carrière à ma vie de
famille c'est ce que j'ai fais
maintenant maintenant que le la menace
plane de plus haut
ça me permet de pouvoir donner au phare
enfants et familles
cet élan pour faire connaître cet
endroit là à tout le monde
les enfants grandissent vous allez
maintenant pouvoir partir en tournée oui
hélas le gala des prix juno le 15 mai
prochain est en nomination dans la
catégorie meilleur album instrumental
oui une victoire ça pourrait changer
beaucoup de choses pour vous mais déjà
déjà cette nomination pour moi m'offre
une grande visibilité je déchire des
gens qui m'ont écrit qui j'avais pas
parler puisqu'elle 20 qui me félicitent
alors déjà cette nomination là me fait
énormément plaisir
alors j'arrête je vous souhaite tout le
meilleur pour le 15 mai prochain merci
beaucoup